[Música]
todas las mañanas a las 7 se repite el
incesante desfile de autos frente a esta
escuela secundaria en los suburbios de
los ángeles
dice trichet white hart lane
las familias vienen aquí a buscar las
comidas para sus hijos
cada vez viene más gente y aprecian
mucho la comida que les damos
a pesar del cierre de las escuelas
públicas y de los comedores para frenar
la propagación del virus algunas
escuelas de los ángeles siguen
distribuyendo comida gratis a los
estudiantes en cada bolsa hay dos
comidas desayuno y almuerzo
para el almuerzo tenemos leche una
hamburguesa con pan verduras y frutas
dalia entregó 300 comidas en una hora
mary martin viene todos los días con sus
hijas
[Música]
mi esposo estuvo sin trabajo por casi
dos meses así que esto nos ayudó
financieramente con el gasto de la
comida
en california el regreso a clases en
2020 es 100 virtual las 10 mil escuelas
públicas permanecen cerradas lo que
perturba la vida diaria de 7 millones de
hogares
[Música]
mary secretaria ejecutiva tuvo que dejar
de trabajar para cuidar de sus tres
hijas
harper de 7 años jane de 4 y rachel de 2
hay que aprender a ser maestro y no
todos están hechos para eso algunos no
tienen lo que se requiere
la clase se hace por videoconferencia
harper cursa primer grado tiene seis
horas de clase virtual y dos horas de
tareas diarias en promedio
pero ya que resulta lo más cool de mesa
y friends
dejad
y el gobernador de california advirtió
que las clases a distancia podrían durar
todo el año escolar esto es un gran
golpe para mary quien teme que esta
situación agrave las desigualdades
sociales escolares
[Música]
y la gente con dinero aquellos que
pueden permitirse tutores o solo apoyo
escolar van a tener una mejor educación
para chiquillas
[Aplausos]
porque en california la quinta economía
mundial las familias más ricas pueden
permitirse el lujo de contratar un tutor
para sus hijos con el fin de reforzar la
educación a distancia
el resultado es la multiplicación de lo
que se denominan potts un proceso de
aprendizaje en forma de cápsula en el
que un puñado de estudiantes se reúnen
para tomar clases particulares
es muy agradable porque el profesor
puede ayudar a cada uno de nosotros
tenemos las mismas tareas de matemáticas
así que es práctico
el profesor especialmente seleccionado
cuesta 50 dólares por hora por
estudiante algunas familias pagan hasta
12 mil dólares por semestre tengo tres
hijas y las tres tienen clases
particulares así que obviamente eso
multiplica el precio por tres pero si no
tienes los medios es imposible por
supuesto que creará desigualdades
para vencer estas desigualdades esta ong
evangélica creó una escuela temporal y
gratuita en su estacionamiento a la
sombra de los paneles solares los padres
pueden dejar a sus hijos aquí antes de
ir a trabajar
[Música]
y cada estudiante se sienta en una mesa
individual para respetar el
distanciamiento social
menos mal que tenemos esta ayuda y es
gratis porque de lo contrario sería muy
difícil si tuvieras que quedarse en casa
mi hija seguramente no recibiría la
educación que necesita porque es difícil
para mi mamá no entiende muy bien inglés
y mucho menos los computadores así que
sería muy diferente
este espacio de estudio está abierto
desde las 9 de la mañana hasta las 2 de
la tarde les permite a los niños
entender mejor sus clases a distancia
los tutores voluntarios proporcionan un
apoyo de tutoría indispensable
especialmente para los más pequeños
las familias que vienen de barrios
pobres o los padres solteros o las
madres que trabajan quién va a educar a
los niños especialmente si los niños
tienen hermanos no es justo para ellos
así que creo que es normal que nuestra
iglesia tome medidas para tratar de
atenuar esas desigualdades
la pandemia de coronavirus ha obligado
al mundo a vivir en internet la ciudad
de los ángeles le prestó un portátil a
cada estudiante pero en eeuu el 13 por
ciento de los hogares no tiene acceso a
internet esta brecha digital aísla a 42
millones de estadounidenses el nivel de
desigualdad es increíble quiero decir
hay familias que pasan horas en
restaurantes de comida rápida para
conectarse a internet o peleando en la
lavandería por una madre que trata de
compartir su conexión con cuatro
personas la brecha digital es muy
profunda no es cuarto en eeuu la
pandemia reveló la magnitud de la brecha
social en el país desde el comienzo del
año nuevo escolar en los ã ngeles seis
mil estudiantes de primaria ya han
abandonado la escuela